peut-on encore sauver la loi travail
votre avis bien sûr non seulement la
sauver mais un mieux la présenter
l'expliquer et tenir compte des
remarques des propositions d'amendements
et modifications qui ont été fait ou qui
vont être faites par les syndicats
réformistes et encore mieux ce sera ok
pourquoi un recul la négociation qui
s'ouvre et qui est celle ouverte avec
les syndicats réformistes elle est
indispensable elle est avec d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et patronales donc c'est bien de les
écouter c'est bien de les entendre
d'avancer des arguments d'entendre des
arguments contre et je pense que il y
aura des modifications qui seront
apportées à cette loi la marquise moi
moi même lamarti pourtant semble mal
engagée non non je ne le crois pas moi
même j'avais mis quelques réserves sur l
revenir sur deux voies d'abord sur sur
la présentation qui avait pas été très à
droite et qui faisait peser a priori une
suspicion ou c'est dans ce pays c'est
comme ça une suspicion de dérive
droitière du texte présenté pourquoi
parce que je crois qu'il avait été dit
que le gouvernement prendrait ses
responsabilités si nécessaire et donc
voila mais je crois qu'il avait été
formulée comme je lai indiqué mais la
vérité défaut première remarque selon
vous c'est le défaut le manque de
pédagogie autorise texte oui défauts
réels de communication oui mais je crois
que ce texte est sorti alors même qu'il
était envoyé au conseil d'état qui n'est
pas encore été présenté au conseil des
ministres
et donc du coup il a fallu remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier qu'elle avance
est possible vous voyez est ce que par
exemple sur l'aim sur le barème des
indemnités aux prud'hommes à est ce
qu'on peut proposer par exemple n'ont
pas un plafond mais un plancher
d'indemnisation exercice de réflexion je
pense que je pense qu'il avait été
laissé une marge de négociation comme
toujours aux parlementaires parce que
finalement ce texte sortant du conseil
d'état envoyés présenté au conseil des
ministres va être mis entre les mains
des parlementaires la commission des
affaires sociales de l'assemblée pour
commencer va dire peut-être le plafond
de kemi est insuffisant quand on regarde
par rapport à l'allemagne
par exemple je crois qu'après 20 ans de
travail c'est 24 mois en allemagne ces
15 mois et qui est proposé donc on peut
corriger cela j'indique quand même que
cette barémisation était déjà dans la
loi dans la loi macron moi j'étais
favorable mais ça a été essentielle mais
oui pourtant d'autres raisons mais free
j'y étais favorable si vous me permettez
je veux dire pourquoi je suis favorable
une barémisation qui peut être
indicative elle n'est peut-être pas
obligatoire elle peut être indicative
pourquoi je suis favorable parce qu'avec
ma collègue christiane taubira on a fait
le tour des prud'hommes et il ya des
situations très différentes d'après
demain un autre et vous avez des
endroits où les salariés peuvent
attendre très longtemps j'ai entendu que
la moyenne était de 18 mois sûrement pas
de la région parisienne puisque il ya
encore un cas de septembre qui n'est pas
traitée entre temps une inégalité
territoriale un manque d'uniformité ou
du oud uniformisation de la
jurisprudence
donc il qu'ils aient un barème de
référence je pense que c'est une bonne
chose
moi les jumelles et resserrent le
mercure serre selon vous ce serait je
pense qu'il faudrait faire comme comme
en allemagne
je pense qu'il faut revoir les
conditions de définition des du
licenciement économique
quelles seraient vos propositions à vous
bien d'allonger déjà les durées de prise
en compte parce que je pense que quatre
mois c'est beaucoup trop court quatre
trimestres dans ce cas c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup trop long pour des
bourses et le quoi leur sert à 5 par
exemple 1 non je pense que celle des ter
d'ici ce même je pense qu'il faut il
faut revoir ça on ne peut pas avoir de
doute sur l'interprétation sur les
causes qui amène à des licenciements
économiques donc cette redéfinition et à
travailler je pense que c'est ce qu'ils
font avec les syndicats réformistes
pourquoi ces mesures arrivent en fin de
quinquennat françois rebsamen match
qu'on a fait déjà beaucoup de choses on
a fait beaucoup de choses et moi ce que
je constate c'est que malheureusement on
ne s'est jamais arrêtée pour dire ce
qu'on fait et ça c'est à des reproches
majeurs que je fais à l'histoire de ce
quinquennat c'est ne jamais avoir
valorisé ce qui avait été dit de ne pas
avoir dès le départ on s'est un peu le
péché originel excusez moi l'expression
de ce quinquennat ne pas avoir dit
quelle était la situation de ne pas
avoir dit qu'est ce qu'on allait faire
d'avoir eu peut-être une vision un peu
optimiste des choses il faut le faut le
reconnaître
françois hollande ça commençait
critiques de françois lepetit non non je
la situation n'est pas facile
elle n'était pas facile quand on est
arrivé tout de suite il ya eu des plans
de licenciements qui avait été repoussée
je peux penser à peugeot à psa moelleux
reçu ici en tant que président de groupe
et patron du groupe uni il s'en sort
maintenant il a fallu quatre ans pour
que le groupe ressort des bénéfices
c'était très important
donc voila et puis il ya eu des choses
de faites des avancées ce jeu les dix la
bouche du réel c'est à dire celles qui
gouvernent en ce moment elle a créé des
nouveaux droits et mais simplement elle
les a pas venir valeur encore la prime
d'activité l'autre jour je regardais on
croirait que c'est là la caf qui
distribue ça comme ça par décision de la
caf très bien la caisse d'allocations
familiales fait très belles choses mais
c'est une décision qui était d'ailleurs
norma loy et qui a été mise en oeuvre au
1er janvier
on peut parler d des retraites après les
carrières longues
on peut parler aussi du droit à la
formation personne n'a parlé vraiment ce
droit à la formation
et puis du compte personnel d'activité
qui est une grande avancée qui est dans
le texte et qui devrait encore renforcer
donc je comprends la question est ce que
c'est un peu la faute quand même de
françois hollande qui n'a pas su mettre
en valeur ce bilan la qui n'a pas
supporté peut-être on n'a pas su aussi
l'expliquer peut-être le parc on a dit
qu'il manquait toujours une ligne
économique
n'at-il pas non plus fait le travail
d'explication qui était nécessaire
peut-être n'at-on pas pris le temps je
me mets dedans
n'at-on pas pris le temps de faire la
pause de l'explication
donc on enchaîne les réformes les unes
après les autres
mais si on s'arrête pas un moment pour
dire voilà ce qui a été fait mal et
français il ne sache pas ils le
connaissent le savent pas ça leur donne
l'impression que tout n'a pas été tenté
contre le chômage
oui même si je le pense j'avais dit que
l'année 2015 serait meilleure que
l'année 2014 ouzou rappelé il y a
aujourd'hui au sens du bit et moi de 3
millions de chômeurs dans en france
voilà au sens du bit et deux millions
huit cent soixante deux millions huit
cent soixante mille selon les chiffres
du pib mais combien de chômeurs en plus
effilé vg qu'un canal françois hollande
si on prend les chiffres du bit et on
n'arrive pas vous savez vous permettez
une b2 minutes d'explications il ya
trois ans une minute
il ya trois ans les chiffres de pôle
emploi et les chiffres du bit et du
bureau international du travail était
identique à 100 milles près il y avait 2
millions neuf cent mille chômeurs
recensés par les deux aujourd'hui il y
en a 2 millions 900 mille recensés par
le bétail 3 millions 500 mille recensés
par pôle emploi
cherchez l'erreur votre explication à
vous mon explication c'est que pôle
emploi n'est pas un outil statistique
martine aubry a publié il ya moins de 15
jours une tribune au vitriol est
désormais les les opposants à la
politique du gouvernement sont
majoritaires au bureau national du ps
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
risque de scission d'explosion de ce
parti comme on a pu l'entendre je me
suis posé la question et j'ai d'ailleurs
fait une tribune sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il y a effectivement mais c'est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire du parti
socialiste il y a de gauche y en a une
qui est plutôt j'allais dire sociale
libérale et puis une autre qui est
plutôt la gauche traditionnelle que l'on
connaît du parti c'est ce qu'il ya c'est
un axe central qui a toujours permis de
réconcilier ces deux gauches pour faire
ce qu'on appelle la synthèse entre les
deux est-ce que l'écart c'est le sens de
votre question aujourd'hui est telle que
ces deux gauches sont irréconciliables
je ne le crois pas je ne le crois pas et
j'ai eu le sentiment hier
bien sûr si je mets à part quelqu'un qui
est peut-être un peu spécifique dans le
parti socialiste comme gérard filoche
mais si on met à part gérard filoche et
bien j'ai eu l'impression que tout le
monde était pour avancer pour qu'il n'y
ait pas non pas un retrait du texte mais
une amélioration du texte nous parlons
du texte sur le travail et donc je pense
que c'est de gauche ne sont pas
irréconciliables et moi je souhaite vous
je sois monsieur le premier ministre
manuel valls a dit
lui a parlé de deux gauches
irréconciliables justement donc vous
inscrivez en faut il penser la pensée
surtout elle à la gauche de jean luc
mélenchon ou effectivement la rupture là
et consommer d'ailleurs on en telle
différence aujourd'hui entre jean luc
mélenchon et les frondeurs du parti
social grande différence c'est que 11
sièges ensemble au bureau national du
parti socialiste en échange on a des
débats on avance ensemble et il ya des
interventions qui sont faites par
certains frondeurs qui sont de qualité
qui permettent d'améliorer encore entre
manuel valls et les frondeurs mais il ya
le débat il ya l'amélioration il sait
d'où l'idée de linguee mais c'est ce
sont deux lignes qui sont différentes
mais qui cohabitent au sein du parti
socialiste et comptent souvent cohabiter
on pourrait dire
rocard je cherche rocard chevènement et
avec mitterrand qui faisait là c est ce
que manuel valls joue pas un peu sa
propre partition malgré tout face à un
hollande qui doit rassembler la gauche
le plus possible manuel valls poursuit
son sillon de réformistes et peut-être
au risque de s'occuper d'eux d'une
partie la gauche oui 7,7 un réformiste
mais moi je pense que c'est un
réformiste de gauche et donc il doit
rester un réformiste de gauche et le
réformisme de gauche c'est une part
essentielle du parti socialiste
il peut mourir le parti socialiste
effectivement il peut exploser le parti
socialiste peut y avoir des fractures et
les médias mais déjà eu quelques départs
ça arrivait dans son histoire
la question qu'on se pose souvent parti
socialiste c'est est ce que le cycle
d'epinay est terminée et donc à chaque
fois qu'il ya un problème la question
revient sur la table il y en a qui m'ont
dit ça et qui dit le cycle d'epinay
terminait les parties ça ça me voir ça
se transforme ça serait génère on le
voit à droite aussi à bout c'est pareil
par contre je suis sûr d'une chose c'est
que la motion ne m'aura pas et ceux qui
de temps en temps s'exprime maintenant
la gauche peut mourir non la gauche
c'est une erreur le parti socialiste
louis - le premier secrétaire jean
christophe cambadélis avait lancé cette
idée d'alliance populaire justement pour
renouveler le parti ça pas l'air de très
bien fonctionner est-ce que la primaire
pour la présidentielle ça pourrait être
un autre moyen de faire ce que les
gauches parle à nouveau de grandes
maisons causant des jean christophe
cambadélis
j'ai assez dubitatif non je suis
dubitatif parce que in fine il faut que
tout le monde soit soit d'accord pour
participer à cela
donc il faut donc s'y lie à une primaire
bon il faut que à la sortie de la
primaire il ya un seul candidat ce
serait d'ailleurs une bonne chose
après est ce que le président de la
république s'il est candidat on met
beaucoup de sylla est ce qu'il a envie
de se plier à cette primaire je n'en
sais rien ça peut être une bonne
occasion s'il y a à la sortie qu'un seul
candidat
mais c'est pas facile de faire une
primaire en étant président de la
république vous en conviendrez surtout
une situation difficile qu'on connaît
que le connaît le pays aujourd'hui une
bonne partie du ps les frondeurs la
motion b de karine berger se sont
prononcés pour la primaire mais aussi
nombreux sujets d'une primaire je pense
une primaire de de toute la gauche j'ai
repris la formule donc des macros un
mélange tout et je pense que c'est une
bonne idée
il faut que tout le monde ait la volonté
quand on fait une primaire de débattre
et d'accepter le résultat de cette
primaire sans passer par la case
hollande
si le président est candidat il dira si
ce pli ou pas à la primaire la primaire
c'est aussi l'occasion de d'affronter ou
de confronter plus exactement des lignes
l'éthique est ce que la participation de
monsieur mélenchon est indispensable
parce que on a pu avoir l'impression que
en faire un préalable était une manière
de dire non à la primaire en fait donc
est ce que vous vous dites oui pourquoi
pas une primaire y compris sans mélanger
y compris sur mélenchon je vous le dis
comprises sans mélenchon mais c'est vrai
que l'idée était quand même d'avoir un
résultat qui qui couvrent tout le champ
de la gauche et de la gauche de la
gauche mais avec mélenchon c'est
extrêmement compliqué vous le savez
peut-être un proche depuis longtemps de
françois hollande françois rebsamen
continuer à le voir régulièrement
beaucoup s'interrogent dans son
entourage je le vois tu es qui pourrait
être candidat en 2017
je me tiens il en a pas parlé pour lui
il en parle à personne je crois pas en
tout le cas il n'y a peut être pas moi
enfin moi je le vois quand je demande à
le voir sans trop de difficulté mais de
cela nous n'avons pas encore parlé
donc on sent beaucoup d'interrogations
dans son entourage certains semble un
petit peu perdues sur sa stratégie est
ce que c'est également votre cas non moi
je pense que le moment venu il fera
connaître son choix
toute façon il peut pas le faire
maintenant puisqu'il a pris moi je crois
à la parole présidentielle
il a dit que sa candidature était liée à
la version de la courbe du chômage et
donc vraiment gagner parce que je le
crois alors après quel est l'outil de
référence
c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé du bit et
vous la dirai bien contré à l'air plus
que des statistiques de pôle emploi
mais de toute façon à terme si le
chômage diminue ça se verra aussi dans
les statistiques de pôle emploi
est ce que si vous étiez encore
parlementaires sénateurs vous voteriez
cette révision constitutionnelle est bon
d'aller poser tout de suite la guérison
est ce que vous voyez il faut je donne
une explication avant d'aller donner de
répondre à cette question je le ferai
premièrement je n'étais pas très chaud
pour la déchéance de nationalité
j'aurais préféré d'indignité nationale
je le dis mais après tout à partir du
moment où ça a été présenté par le
président de la république que envisagé
par le président de la république devant
le congrès unanime
debout à l'applaudir je me dis que ce
n'est pas rien ce qui m'a le plus
surpris c'est de voir que des gens qui
ne s'était pas préoccupé de ce sujet
avant les attentats et avant la
déclaration du président de la
république n'avait jamais signifié
contesté le fait que la france n'ait
jamais ratifié la convention de 61 et
qu'elle ne l'est que signé mais je me
suis dit c'est quand même étonnant que
ceux qui sont contre la déchéance
pendant tant d'années
il n'est jamais demandé à ce que la
france ratifié la convention de 61 vous
savez la convention de 61 et l'actualité
quand on a beaucoup plus parlé bien sûr
mais elle a été signée avec une clause
qui permettait l'apatridie pour ce
record pour y avait atteinte grave à
l'état donc cette clause elle a été mise
en scène réserve qui a été fait par la
france elle elle est là depuis 61
elle est pas de reconstitution non mais
elle est là puis 61 c'est vrai mais les
pas dans la constitution vrai donc le
débat a rejailli mois à partir du moment
où je les dis le président de république
a pris cet engagement moi j'ai j'y
souscris mais j'ai fait une remarque une
deuxième remarque il peut pas y avoir de
différence entre les français
donc je pense que oui binationaux
doivent être sortis de cela et pourquoi
pas parce que il peut pas y avoir d'un
côté des français entièrement à part et
de l'autre des français à part on ne
peut pas y avoir non plus d'apatrides et
d'autres se contentant manuel valls à
l'instant il va y avoir des apatrides
visiblement moi je suis pour que le
texte lui je le dis ici je suis au sénat
je vous connaissais la magie juan
conseils à donner
et caetera je trouve que la formule de
manuel valls août à l'heure était plutôt
joli désacralisée
scott thomas voilà c'est quand même
c'est vrai que ça sera à fronts
renversés de voir le sénat aujourd'hui
sacralisé d'une certaine manière
l'engagement du président de la
république moi je pense que le travail
qui a été fait à l'assemblée nationale
est un beau travail et donc je pense que
cette affaire a assez duré et je pense
que le sénat devrait aujourd'hui validé
la proposition qui est transmise par
l'assemblée nationale sénat a voté
conforme
je vous dis je oui je pense qu'ils ont
assez il y en a assez
alors que nous faut sortir par le haut
oui vote conforme oui je pense qu'il
faudrait à votre confort faudra aller
vite
je pense que les français sont lassés de
ce débat parce que tout le monde sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de symbolique c'est
très important
beaucoup de symbolique derrière ça mais
peu d'efficacité finalement ça n'appelle
que vous lancez à la droite aujourd'hui
mois sur wii je voudrais dire écoutez on
arrête
et sinon si c'est pour répartir pendant
des mois moi je lui dirai au président
de la république mais coûtera peut-être
pas il faut retirer ça il faut aller les
sénatoriales
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle a le sens des
responsabilités et françois rebsamen
c'est à dire que si jamais voté conforme
aujourd'hui revenir à un congrès à
versailles
moi je pense oui je pense que je si
c'est pas le cas il n'y aura pas de
congrès je ne sais pas ça dépend pas de
moi maintenant je vous ai dit qu'elle
était ma position pour le président la
république prendra une option d'autant
bien vous seriez parlementaire
aujourd'hui vous voteriez conforme le
texte est venue de loïc bhend moi oui
moi oui j'avais fait mes remarques avant
j'aurais préféré la dignité mais
j'expliquais si vous voulez l'union
nationale où c'était le sermonne
versailles comme dim
manuel valls il récolte les critiques de
votre gauche les critiques de la droite
c'est échec sur toute la ligne
ça n'a pas duré longtemps ce sentiment
d'union nationale et je le regrette
profondément
il ya eu quelqu'un ici un sénateur que
je respecte
ancien premier ministre qui a fait des
déclarations je parle de jean pierre
raffarin que j'ai trouvé tout à fait
estimable qui tendait la main à cet
instant oui je le pense
mais la vie politique a repris le débat
politique ou politicien a repris trop
vite le dessus
moi je pense sincèrement que dans la
période qu'on a connu
je lui ai même dit un gouvernement vous
voyez où jusqu où j'allais un
gouvernement d'union nationale
correspondait à l'état d'urgence que sur
le moment pour le moment sur le moment
où la nation après après le match que
personne n'en veut et personne n'a
répondu ni dans un sens ni dans un autre
parti politique sont repartis dans leurs
débats l'affrontement gauche droite a
repris un an le bon vieux clivages un à
un an de la présidentielle c'est
peut-être comme ça que ça se passe
ce mode de scrutin génère cela donc
c'est tout cela qu'il faut revoir à
dijon de dix jours est-ce qu'on vous
parle de ce texte très sincèrement on
m'en a beaucoup parlé au mois de
décembre pour après les voeux du
président puisqu'il avait évoqué cela
dans ses voeux depuis on en parle depuis
20 ans